I have to tell you this story so I think
having the double mastectomy was the
worst and and the drains they put in not
to get too graphic I think it hit a
nerve so I was always fighting with my
doctors for more pain medication yeah
okay so there was a day that brains were
out gorgeous sunny day feeling free for
the first time I had these plate glass
windows under this patio and WHAM this
little Finch hit the window and fell on
the bricks dead and I went great it's
always something so I opened the door
and I put him in my arms and hands and I
sat out you know how sometimes you think
you can heal something yeah oh it's
blasphemy sitting there and all of a
sudden he flips over in my hand
and I mean his head was hanging off my
hand before and he flips over and I
could feel his tiny little claws and
then his wings were fine his beak was
fine and my niece was there and she's
like the francis of assisi of our family
so she said she just said oh he wants
some water and I thought dude you know
go uh-huh and so we put a little cup of
water and we put her there she said now
leave him alone if she knows I want to
go mess with him
but then I couldn't leave him alone and
I went back and he flew off and I told
Linda I said he flew away and she said
are you getting the message and at first
I thought I can heal like Jesus
[Applause]
ugly and I and she said no you thought
you were dead
but now you can fly into a no life oh my
gosh I love your knees I do too and she
just I mean after that I just thought
you know everything's gonna be okay
yeah those little moments man he may
still get your ex yeah this a moment of
grace mm-hmm
any melody and yeah I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this